lit the culling games begin we've
actually made it to the start of the
most insane Saga so far always got to
say so far because who knows when the
goat father guiller will drop his next
Masterpiece The Saga here makes Shibuya
feel like the Prelude it's made out to
be but he Mastermind himself kinjaku
everything to do with the culling games
has taken what we know which is YouTube
Kaizen and absolutely flipped it on its
head but firstly just before I do dive
into giga's nut intertwined sensation of
a story I'm going to be doing something
slightly different here with this Arc
pretty much in like I've said due to the
fact this is more or less going to
evolve into its own kind of saga I'm
going to break down each respective
Colony as its own arc starting with the
first Tokyo Colony just before we do get
into that though if you are new around
here and want to watch more stuff just
like this then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with pushing my content into a
bunch of new amazing people but anyway
enough of that sit back and relax as we
jump back into did you see Kaizen so as
we start back out we find ourselves in
the middle of a Japanese criminal trial
it's explained that in Japan 99 of
criminal trials into their guilty
verdict a young man sitting opposite the
newest Qi hegaruma who I introduced
right at the end of the last video
explains that he had a cat who was lost
and while looking for it he was
confronted by the popos being struck
with a difficult Choice the young man
decided to flee because his cat would
have died as where he loves it's a rule
that he can't own any pets we find that
in March of 2016 a mother and daughter
were both slain and morioka City this
caused the prosecutors of the case to
instantly suspect the young man they
arrested him and charged him a suspicion
of murder and robbery after Kisa fled
the initial questioning by police
officers they followed him to his home
and found it bloody blade which is like
bro why have you got this knife dude it
ain't exactly looking good for you here
anyway once a lab analysis was completed
it confirmed that the blood on the knife
was matched to the DNA of the two
victims despite the outstanding evidence
and practically being caught red-handed
by the cops keita insisted that he was
innocent while reviewing the case with
his
higuruma explains that Kita told him he
picked up the knife even though it
wasn't his obviously Shimizu doesn't
believe that that could have possibly
happened and instead thinks that he fled
from the authorities because he was
simply guilty here for some reason
hegaruma argues that he only fled
because in the past he'd been illegally
harassed by police officers causing him
to always be weary of them he claimed he
was going to give the knife to the
police later because his hostile was
skitchy as hell and didn't allow him to
call the police there the reason for
this is because his job around the
hostel was to care for the elderly who
have nowhere to go employees in the
hostel are given a place to stay and
some food but I only paid money under
the table on the New Year while at the
same time still being overcharged each
month for rent obviously as you could
imagine this affects how all of the
residents would live more than a few of
the residents who do live there have
criminal records and ever since the 2011
earthquake Relief Fund money started
pouring into the region causing more
shady non-profit businesses to begin
appearing higuruma believes it's likely
that the weapon was actually lying
around and cater indeed is telling the
truth so well obviously big kuruma is a
freaking G man is working on the higher
cognitive frequency and is probably the
only damn lawyer in Japan that is
adamant and taking on the courts
themselves plus freaking Giga again
added in that 2011 tsunami slash
earthquake reference there I absolutely
love how it makes us feel as though this
could actually be going down in Japan
right now or he's retelling an event
that actually affected the world over
the past few years anyways anyways
hegaruma forms a plan to take on the
case he'll continue gathering
information while his overworked
assistant takes care of pretty much
everything else the sexy big brain Duo
go ham working tirelessly until the day
of the trial then on the day they
somehow managed to earn an innocent
verdict for keita Shimizu was surprised
they actually got the verdict but
higaruman knows the prosecutors will
immediately appeal in a post-trial
meeting hikarumo reveals to case her the
nothing from the robbery that was stolen
was ever found in his room and someone
disappeared from the residence soon
after the crime happened above
everything else keita also appeared on a
convenience store camera at literally
the same time as the time of the death
hearing this he thanks hegaruma but the
lawyer simply emphasizes that there will
be a second trial sobbing Peter
specifies us that he means he just wants
to thank her garuma for believing in him
however as per usual at the retrial the
broken Japanese Judicial System
unfortunately found cater guilty and the
young man was sentenced to life in
prison it's explained that independent
defense lawyers like hegaruma rely on
limited funding and no Workforce public
prosecutors have access to tax money and
much greater Manpower because of this no
new evidence was ever presented at the
second trial and the court passed out
his sentence on the shaky argument that
there was no reason to suspect the
random person who just happened to go
missing straight after the murder which
is like Nadu that pit guy straight up
gaptive because he committed the murder
and now you're completely locking up an
innocent person here a cane anyway
because of this a third trial before the
highest court is unlikely as they refuse
to hear most cases hidden Affair hearing
is improbable and the system itself
unfairly branded cater is guilty from
the very beginning and sadly this is
just the reality of the situation in
most countries from the US to New
Zealand as soon as you have Blake being
said in front of the jury you already
have somewhat of a bad connotation put
over your head it was so like moral of
the story obviously is just don't get
yourself in a situation where you're
going to be charged for something in
court obviously you can't always do that
but anyway disparate and angry caser
looks at hegaruma with sorrow and
disappointment in his eyes standing
there shocked her groomer just asks
himself why his clients always look at
him this way losing touch with reality
for a moment he thinks back to a
conversation he had about his mental
state there he replied that it was his
intention to save the week he's always
been the type of person who couldn't
just ignore things Justice is supposed
to be blind and people close their eyes
to spare themselves from The Hearth
truths of reality but even if he's the
only one who guruma says that he wants
to keep his eyes back in court now the
judge announces that if there are any
objections that they must be filed
within 15 days not freaking happy though
and wanting to make a damn change pick a
room abruptly interrupts and slams his
table with a mallet that turns out to be
a judge's gavel of his own this leaves
absolutely everyone in the courtroom
surprised and as shizimu begins to move
away a large dark curse begins to form
behind Haka rumor refusing to allow the
trial to end in this unjust Manor
higrumah snaps and tells everybody that
nobody is allowed to leave because now
they are having a re-trial as per usual
with other gecko you're skipping away
from this straight away and going over
elsewhere just before 6 a.m back on the
1st of November when we find ourselves
with kinjaku who's legit like creeping
onto Starsky by the way just gonna blow
your minds if you guys haven't realized
this as well this is the freaking girl
from the very first episode or chapter
yuji's old friend like the one that like
he saved right at the beginning so what
the actual hell does kinjaku have in
store here like with her anyways anyways
petrified as you would be with waking up
and finding a man like in your beard
sitsuko asks who this weirdo is as
explained to her that he is a sorcerer
who placed a barrier over scene die and
that the region has been chosen to host
a lethal contest where players will
fight to the death the remains of an
execution site nearby serves as the
center of the barrier with a radius of
around five to six kilometers which is
super interesting like I wonder if he
had to set up a bunch of these like
execution sites throughout each barrier
in his thousand years or so proceeding
this event Sasuke who are already inside
of the barrier are given one chance to
leave so this explains the confusion on
how they were going to be like notified
of the current situation with the
barrier he says that as she chooses to
leave she'll awaken outside of the
barrier confused with his word him of
just like everything CIS ask you
questions if she's still dreaming that
kunjaku replies that the space between
dreams and reality is a curse I don't
know if this dude was the only one to
show up personally to Sasaki but he
takes a hold of her hand and warns her
to be careful then as he slowly guides
her to the safety of the barrier exit we
get to witness the current Carnage
taking place across the battlefield then
skipping back to the duo just before
they part ways for Good King who
mysteriously thanks asarski for getting
along with his son and suddenly after
she wakes up outside of the barrier with
the other OG friend from the first
chapter or episode a Gucci who's glad to
have found someone that he knows so it's
always good to see a Gucci doing well
again as we left on the note that he was
in hospital and everything anyway he
points out the gigantic barrier wall and
explains that everyone saw the same man
during their dream however to further go
on to my point on him physically mixing
her unlike the others Sasuke asks if the
man had mentioned his son but that isn't
the case with him skipping away from
that now and back to the present day
which is the 11th of November Eugene
Megami continued planning for their part
of the game they're unable to find a
player named Angel but apparently
they'll know who it is when they say
them Baker Curry decides that him and
his boy panda will go over the Tokyo 2
Colony while Yuji and migami will head
into the number one and Carrara stays
outside of the barrier by the way it's
recently come to my attention that
apparently Carrara is neither a male or
a female so apologies for not realizing
that the last video but it does go to
show just how like in touch Giga is dude
just knows everything that's going on
with her culture and today's generations
and all I absolutely love it anyway
Curry plans to handle this mysterious
GMA kushimo himself since they did
player with the most points and likely
as the strongest Yuji begins to bring up
that perhaps he and Megami shouldn't
travel together due to how zakona has
been acting hella suss with him recently
however making me just tells Yuji to
just shut up and stop being so
self-centered because the others can't
exactly change their roles after a
little squabble between the boys it
skips forth to 12 p.m the next day when
everyone all reaches their designated
barriers inside of Tokyo before entering
kogan explains to them that inside the
barriers the lethal competition known as
the culling game is taking place and
asks if the new players are willing to
enter and declare their participation in
the game they're probably the exact same
time Mega me Yuji Panda and takari don't
hesitate and all agree to enter diving
straight into Tokyo Colony number one we
find this babe honey asking for a signal
from a doge he's forcing to work for her
called Ren he tells her that he can't do
anything though if no one shows up which
leaves hanyu annoyed she activates her
curse technique snapping your hair to
this real light topaz looking chair on
her back and threatens to run run over
if he mounts her off again outside and
approaching the colony making me
explains to the absolutely confused Yuji
that they just need to be weary of
incarnated sorceress that have lived
throughout the past eras still somehow
confused over this Mega me says that
some of the players are from over a
thousand years ago and even those from
only 100 or 200 years ago have a
completely different mindset compared to
the modern day ones first and foremost
they are Sorcerers who valued life
differently and fighting to the death
was a normal thing for them some people
even desire to achieve an honorable end
in battle and that's why Mega me thinks
they've agreed to become players to
achieve the warrior-like deaths they
couldn't before nigami doesn't believe
that they'll be able to negotiate with
past Sorcerers to which he adds on that
they need to be wary not of just people
but curse Spirits as well they they
knock on the barrier wall of Tokyo
Colony number one and immediately kogane
appears to greet them it announces that
the Cullen game is taking place inside
and anyone who enters will become a
player in the deadly competition Megami
declares his participation but oddly
like maybe you guys all saw but migami
doesn't exactly pick up on it here kogay
never asks Yuji if he actually wants to
join the game determined to save his
sister though mehmi reminds Yuji that
the first move is to get information on
hiromi higuruma the duo steps inside the
barrier however they both suddenly
separated sent randomly to different
locations inside of the colony Yuji
finds himself falling from the sky
confused by his circumstances while also
wondering where in the world Mega me is
as then explained to us that when a
player enters the game's barrier they
transferred to one of nine different
locations student individuals position
themselves at those locations to
literally spawn Camp unsuspecting people
who don't know this unspoken rule
skipping back over to the sump who's
actually just one of those spawn campers
he notices Yuji falling from the sky and
uses a guiding like baton to Signal hanu
using uku's technique to propel herself
can you bursts through the air raming
directly into the chest of Yuji she
carries on and smashes them straight
through two buildings with an attack
that would have utterly pulverized most
players however you hear his just
freaking belt different like man is
constructed of a different material and
somehow he quickly recovers from the
impact surprising hanu sliding back
across the roof of a building Gucci
manages to get some foot in and takes
his fighting stance recognizing her
opponent's toughness hanu calls your
partner to her side but Yuji quickly
throws you rock he picked up in the
previous attack that had tanyu in his
stomach seriously injuring her heavily
injured she slowly begins to lose
altitude before falling into the
building below her behind a surprised
Yuji hanu's partner who's the slight
bulky ass dude called hubba appears
using his helicopter-like curse
technique to levitate he angrily demands
to know what Yuji has done to his woman
over on a nearby building Ren notices
that helper has appeared and that hanu
was easily taken down thinking on this
newcomer for a second Ren thinks that he
might know him before remembering
someone named itadori meanwhile mikami
who I tell you ain't no simp knocks down
a female player and draws his curse tall
she asks him why he'd do that but Mega
me angrily replies that it's because she
literally attacked him he asked this
hella cute girl like oh my Lord their
hairstyle is too freaking fire I kill
geek anyways anyways he asks her for him
fall in hug Aroma but she instantly
starts acting difficult she says that
she'll only give him the information if
he accesses her Knight and protects her
reluctantly our Knight agrees but not on
the way she wants which annoys her he
tells her to walk in front of her and
only promises to protect her if she's
telling the truth if this isn't the case
he implies that he'll literally go demon
time on your ass and get some points
unlike Yuji Mega me literally does not
care about racking up 100 points on his
own if need be unintimidated though the
girl responds with a devious smirk and
tells Mega me to instead call her Remy
back over the battle with Yuji he begins
his fight with cover by tossing a stone
charged with cursed energy directly at
him this doesn't pose much of a threat
though as he easily destroys it with his
fast rotating propeller seeing this Yuji
uses the opening to close the distance
he runs across the roof of the building
and uses his correct physical strength
to LEAP into the air grabbing his
enemy's leg he then flanks his ass
directly down and drags him through the
side of the building utterly destroying
nerds hubba manages to get loose and
tries counter-attacking but Yuki sees it
in time and decides to retreat he
realizes the hubba isn't taking
advantage of The High Ground and only
attacks with the weapon on his head by
the way I just noticed but both of the
people ugs fought here so far have had
some like weird ass obsession with
turning their heads into some sort of
like military vehicle like hanu's got
her jet here and obviously this dude's
got some kind of fetish for helicopters
anyways anyways Yuji ends up leading the
student doors where it's much more
confined however hubba instantly drops
down after Yuji confident that his
propellers can literally shred through
everything inside finding him hubba
spins towards his opponent head first
like a drill attempting to a Blitzer
race everything in his path thinking
yuhi believes that hanyu was easily
defeated because of her hair based
technique that left the rest of her body
unguarded by cursed energy but no matter
how tough it is the kid will always
remain a vital spot so as long as he can
hit them without touching the propellers
you hear is confident that he'll be able
to destroy his opponent it's his
adversary finally closes in yujiko's
pure demon mode and punches hubba
directly in the top of the head and
simply stopping him in his tracks and
leaving the bulked up dude bleeding from
the top of his head still despite his
brain getting absolutely pinged around
inside of his own skull hubba remains
standing he begins laughing and
overconfidently assumes that Yuji had
broken his hand then just as he says
that Yuji is finished our boy just
doesn't even care and casually finishes
hubba off with a kick sitting him flying
back through the corridor standing there
shaking off the damage that he just took
newshu realizes that he still needs to
ask this man about her garuma yet as the
confused Yoji goes to ask him Ren
suddenly appears behind him saying that
he knows about hagaruma and asks a few G
actually remembers him Ren by the way is
just another random dude from like a
sister school to yuji's that kinjaku has
probably done the dirty with he wasn't
friends with Yuji and Yuji funnily
enough doesn't even recall who he is
here Ren notices that Yuji is obviously
suspicious of him so he says he really
only knows him as the tiger of West
Junior High which embarrasses yuchi back
with mikami as he walks through the
streets of the Remy he asks her if she's
not a sorcerer from the past she
confirms she's from the modern day
prompting Mega me to question her reason
for fighting to which he explains that
plays who began inside the colony have
been experiencing the culling game for
12 days already she's not participating
in the game to win most people like her
are just trying to survive Remy claims
that she's seen players go mad with
power and tells Mega me to stop thinking
in terms of time periods as it's
pointless now hearing this making me
realizes that he accidentally mislead
Yuji with their plans earlier due to
this Mega me tells Remy to wait up and
reveal where she's leading home and
certainly raging at him though Remy
refuses because because making me could
simply eliminate her after he gets this
information but he argues that he could
lose like a rumors location if Remy ends
up dying at the same time deji asks
renway's helping since he was just with
the previous Sorcerers but Ren reveals
he was being forced to work with them
and would have been eliminated soon
anyway hearing this Yuji finally stops
and asks where hegaruma is then there's
some pure cheekiness is revealed through
Wren and Remy the heck rumors location
as in one of two different areas so
obviously one person is lying here Ren
claims hegaruma is an ikibukuro or Remy
says that he's in Shinjuku having both
gained this info separately Yuji and
Megami hope that the other is headed to
the same destination yet as we know one
of them is indeed being misled and it's
instead shown that someone has actually
taken them to another mysterious but
absolutely ripped man hoarding receipts
skipping away for a second we go into a
flashback where we find Ren and another
student who are approached by bullies
big print Wren using his like 1000 Q
didn't stand up to the aggressors but he
knew how to act so that the bullies
wouldn't get agitated and would instead
stop bothering him he knew the bullies
were arrogant despite not being smart or
athletic so he focused on staying out of
their way here we smiled and went with a
flow even at other people's experience
because nobody would bother him however
in that same instance how young Legion
refuses to sit by and watch someone else
get bullied Ren who was just standing
there just assumed that another
had showed up who didn't know like how
to avoid travel but it turned out to be
the infamous tiger of West Junior High
big freaking Yuji itadori the bullies
attempted to beat on the newcomer but
all three of them are utterly photorized
and brutally knocked out just by a
single head each turning to Ren Yuji
asks if he's next but Rin was just too
shocked and could only stutter in
response skipping back to reality and
over with the two lovebirds is a hit off
at a station migami immediately
expresses some concerns about going
through ikibukuro he believes that they
should have taken a more direct route to
Shinjuku instead but Remy argues that
the root is simple for her and she is a
base nearby where she wants to rest and
bathe meanwhile Ren takes Yuji to a
theater in akibukuro the hegaruma uses
as his base excited to have quickly
located his Target Yuji thanks Ren
concerned though Ren asks Yuji if he's
really going to go inside alone to which
he says that he's in a hurry to meet up
with an ally and a Shores run that he'll
be able to escape if anything goes wrong
yuchi like the Happy he is Skips
off into the theater without a care in
the world while Ren Le means sitting
idly by unable to stop him after
entering the theater and rolling down
some stairs someone else introduces
himself as Reggie but as per usual with
gigay and him skipping around all
throughout this like section of the arc
right here he's not greeting Yuji No in
fact migami has walked into an ambush of
his own inside of Remy's so-called base
where another player was indeed waiting
for him Reggie reveals to mihime that
Remy had tricked him which immediately
sends Mega me into an utter rage pissed
off he looks back at Remy who's simply
tries to taunt him now that she's
supposedly safe not worried at all
though our female loving Mega me tells
her to shut up then instantly summons
has a Divine dog totality stating that
they're wasting his time remember how
Yugi was just surprised before this well
Eugene upon entering the theater finds
hegoroma chilling in a freaking bathtub
filled with water while he's still fully
clothed in his suit but man I love
figarooma dude gets the coolest
introductions and honestly looks so
freaking clean here I'm not sure what
film as well this is from but I know for
a fact that this whole clothed and
chilling in a bathtub is definitely from
a movie that I've seen but I just can't
remember the exact one right now anyway
lying there and that Bell Delphine holy
bath water hegaruma claims that it feels
better than he expected we're just like
holy dude chill man he explains that
he's going off the rails and doesn't
care about anything anymore so he's
trying stuff he never thought he would
have done in the past hearing him ramble
Yuji finds it kind of funny but since
he's the Pro-Tech he tries to get
straight to the point and asks the
suited man to talk but the lawyer claims
it cost 5 000 Yen per every half hour
hegaruma says that this was just a joke
though because he wanted to play the
part of a greedy lawyer for once Yuji
who's obviously like yo what the is
this dude on quickly realizes that he's
not an incarnated sorcerer from the past
to do a genius editori deducing this he
believes that they can communicate and
make a deal instead of fighting but you
know if you go for Remy's saying then
right now your he is utterly stuffed
either way and won't be able to tour
anyways anyways YouTube Reveals His and
mega me's points plan but hearing it
hagarama climbs Because he believes the
Cunningham presents a few possibilities
he's interested in so obviously our
ex-loy has gone a little bit nuts here
with a sudden power and wants to know
more about the rules of the culling game
in comparison to that of societies
heguru presents the question of what if
the Cullen game punished rule Breakers
without charges prosecutions or trials
we're fully in that Law and Order Arc
right now boys Japan's Rogue lawyer
recognizes that the rules of the game
aren't perfect but he still wants to
preserve the basic mechanics of the game
and see the acoustic Nikki removal
process for himself Yuji who's probably
like just chill man tries to get
hegaruma to understand that the cunning
game is a ritual for sacrificing
everyone in Japan but he just doesn't
believe it instead he points out that
the cullingham's rules celebrate
permanence something Yuji can't argue
with because he literally doesn't even
understand it himself when narrative
options and patience Yuji let the muscle
hide ears Ops for his own form of
persuasion getting ready to throw some
freaking hands he demands that he let
him use his points however soaking wet
just took myself after reading this Arc
hegaruma stands up out of the tub and
asks Yuji if he's ever killed anyone
then armed with the gavel in his hand
and his shikagami by his side hikarumo
claims that it feels better than he ever
expected standing opposite him Yuji
knows hagaroma has eliminated at least
20 players because of this he decides to
stay on the defensive to anticipate an
attack unexpectedly though your he is
caught off guard as her groomer
instantly activates his domain expansion
deadly sentencing noting the immediate
danger Yuji rushes the lawyer and tries
to attack him before the curse technique
can activate Yuji throws a head kick but
his foot slows and slops right before it
can reach his opponent higuruma explains
to him that his domain forbids the use
of physical violence on each other which
causes Yuji to be transported back to
the other end of his Court's room
judgment which is the name of the
shikigami begins stating that Yuji is
Under Suspicion of entering the Pachinko
parlor on July 16 2017 in Sendai City
despite being underage Yuji isn't sure
what's happening at first until he
remembers The Parlor the Judgment was
referring to as per usual Yuji literally
can't lie and makes it pretty obvious
that he has been there higuruma explains
that judgment knows everything about
everyone and the domain it's explained
that hegaruma isn't privy to all of this
information beforehand and the verdict
is solely decided by the arguments
presented in this courtroom additionally
as a confused Yuji reacts to this some
evidence in a folder randomly appears
that's been submitted by judgment to be
looked over it's not necessarily
conclusive but our boy who physically
like cannot lie won't be informed of
what's inside either instead his goal is
to defend his case and to spell all
doubt to win an innocent verdict from
judgment so yes well you all thought the
perfect preparation Arc was crazy or
some of the techniques like Remy's and
how they all worked but I can tell you
for a fact that father Gage was just
warm enough as holy pencil right there
like my brain writing these scripts
sometimes and figuring out how these
techniques exactly work as mental
everything just feels so well thought
out with him anyways anyways this
trial-based Goose technique makes Yuji
realize that he's being prosecuted by an
actual lawyer the absence of a fatal
attack in hagarumus domain makes you
remember a past convo worthy thumb or
explain that a domain expansion was a
more common technique for Sorcerers of
the past because they didn't incorporate
guaranteed hurts what is different to
today's as I think so far throughout the
series everyone who's cast a domain has
had a sure hit guarantee old-school
domains used to be used in such a way to
force people to obey specific conditions
of the acura's technique constructing a
domain where they can't miss attack like
dickons or jogos for example requires a
lot of skill and the number of users
will of them heavily decreases over time
due to them fighting obviously which is
why most people have to bear on
Surviving the short head domain to
defeat the enemy whereas Yuji surmises
that hegoroma's domain is the old school
type meaning it isn't necessarily lethal
and can't physically harm him if he
sticks to the conditions that hagaruma
explained beforehand continuing to
explain a rumor says that both
participants each have one chance to
make a statement once both parties have
made their case against each other
judgment will deliver a verdict yuhi
asks what happens if he's found guilty
the Higa rumor isn't sure how to answer
that question instead he tells Yuji
here's one of three options as a
response silence confession or denial
surprised juji asks if it's fine if he
lies in court to whatsukuroma points out
that there will be no need for trials if
everyone was just honest in their first
place then tells Yuji to hurry his slow
ass up and make his statement because
judgment is impatient taking a moment
yuhi thinks about how to properly defend
himself he knows that he did go into the
pachenko parlor that day and even one on
the machines this this means that line
is his way to get off clean but he isn't
sure what the evidence is after going
over all of the hypotheticals if you
decide to go with the second option
which was confession and claims that he
only went inside the building to use the
bathroom however hegarum is a part of
the goddamn Yu-Gi-Oh universe and had
set up his trap he instantly reveals it
retorting with the evidence which turns
out to be a damn photo of Yuji inside of
the Parlor using their cash exchange
absolutely dumbfounded with his own
stupidity Fuji face Palms while Siro
Kaiba himself adds that after gaining
all of this evidence it puts a supposed
restroom story into question because of
this he states that is certain Yuji into
the Pachinko parlor with the intent of
playing on the machines Yuji trying to
be cheeky asks the lawyer what law he's
breaking in to which is explained that
the premises forbids the entry of miners
currently in Japan there aren't any laws
for actually punishing those miners over
this but it's still considered illegal
puzzled he states that this isn't an
unfair trial puzzle he states that this
is an unfair trial because there's
nothing he could have said to when
however hagarumu reveals that Japan only
forbids miners to gamble meaning cash
exchanges are separate entities in
themselves because of this if Yuji
wanted to win the verdict all he
actually needed to say was they'd never
seen The pachanko Parlor before having
come to a conclusion judgment finds Yuji
guilty since 18 ham to confiscation
finally we can stop with all the Yip yep
and get to the proper bait down material
and like y'all don't realize this but
after this fight here we don't see Yuji
for an extremely long time to savor this
fight before we move on to some of the
newest and coolest characters in manga
anyways so randomly the domain is
dispelled and judgment disappears as it
does so he can rumor immediately attacks
by throwing his gavel which connects
with yuji's arm dealing way more damage
than it should have smelling blood in
the water hecarima closes the distance
and summons his gavel back to his hand
he then charges it with cursed energy to
increase its size and proceeds to smash
through yuji's defense sending him
crashing through several seats in the
theater hitting back up YouTube realizes
that he's in an even worser to equation
than originally thought now he's
completely lost the ability to
manipulate cursed energy but honestly
hegaruma probably got the worst match up
here as we all know for a fact that our
boy's physical strength is suddenly
broken it's comparable to having a
freaking Heavenly restriction on himself
continuing to attack a guru launches and
smashes down his Mallet atop Yuji saying
it in time though Yuji jumps back to
avoid it but this insanely big brain
lawyer makes the gavel appear in his
other hand allowing him to quickly
attack yet again after the barrage ends
yuchi who had narrowly managed to dodge
tries to counter-attack with an elbow
bag Aroma instead of switching hands
like he just was now morsely shape of
the gavel into a flexible Hawk which
manages to wrap around yuji's elbow
before tossing him away it's actually
crazy when you think about how strong
higarumo really is like the still didn't
have a cursed technique up until
extremely recently and only in the
basics of barrier techniques by
analyzing his own domain expansion
somehow this mad genius had worked back
from there and gained in an instinctive
grasp of how to reinforce his body curse
energy so somehow within just 12 days of
Awakening higuruma managed to blossom
into a fighter who's comparable to
someone like freaking an army or even
meimei but probably even stronger before
entering the colony so literally for no
point he exercised a few cursed spirits
and then soon after has eliminated at
least 20 players becoming one of the two
current Front Runners in terms of points
standing there he asks Yuji if he can't
control his curse energy which confuses
him because he thinks hegaruma is the
reason for it but apparently the
confiscation penalty takes away the
person's ability to use techniques in
the first place so because Yuji doesn't
possess any kind of technique the
effects literally fell to stopping him
from utilizing cursed energy altogether
concerned over this hiruma quickly
surmises that it must be due to an
incredible physical prowess determined
to Christ Yuji with all of his might
higrumah shifts his gavel into a staff
and attacks with a flurry of swings
using his insane agility though Lucy is
able to avoid each swing then grabs onto
the staff's middle section only for
hicaroma to make a theme instantly
vanish before he can pull it away
jumping back Eugene kicks the bathtub
directly towards the lawyer however he
simply destroys it with his gavel
unleashing a rush of water and broken
tub pieces erupting through the water
hegaruma increases his gavel to a
freaking massive size and slams it down
on top of Yuji however like someone
please explain to me how even this isn't
enough to crush Yuji it even freaking
impresses her garuma who Compares his
experience to fighting an indestructible
doll Yuji who realizes that he's in deep
water though considers like a Roman's
nickname to be exceptionally strong and
things that this muscles will mean that
there's some sort of relative weakness
he frantically records his interactions
beforehand and remembers the mental
notes he made about the trail-based
curse technique then in a moment that
pulls even me away every time I read it
Yugi calls out and demands a retrial
like how does he even know what this is
in the first place because of this it
instantly transports them both inside of
the domain to some sort of momentary
safety due to what happened in the
previous trial if Yuji doesn't confess
his gel outright he can request a free
trial that can't be refused yet this
play of his utterly backfires is in this
new trial judgment announces that our
boy is being accused of mass murder and
Shibuya on October the 31st 2018. then
like last time hagarumo received some
evidence to go over but before he even
has the chance to speak who she
immediately confesses his guilt as we
all know by now he won't let alone can't
lie and will refuse to deny what
happened shocking the lawyer bleeding
from his eyes with rage the eraped
Judgment declares Yuji as guilty he
punishes Yuji with confiscation again as
well as an additional punishment which
turns out to be no other than the
freaking death penalty so for those of
you who are wondering yes this is the
third time now that a boy has been
sentenced to death in some kind of
manner after judgment gives Yuji his
penalty hagarum is gavel transforms into
an Executioner's sword which has the
added effect of being able to kill its
targets with just one cart hegaruma
believes emphasizing with people means
understanding all of their weaknesses
but he can't help but perceive that
fragility itself is ugly including Yushi
everyone is weak and ugly to himself
regardless of the aspirations to improve
in life while hagaroma continues
screaming who he tries to keep him back
by launching several theater chairs in
his Direction the impedance cheeky old
self luji throws his jiu Jutsu hijacket
a distractic Aroma leaving her a moment
to get in and behind him quickly
higgerum returns but in that moment also
notices Yuji who now throws his hoodie
and manages to block the lawyer's sight
momentarily dropping to the floor Yuji
throws a sweeping Kirk a hagaroma who's
somehow able to keep up is able to just
jump above it as he floats there he can
remove appears to land his final blow
but the Executioner sword while Yuji
below appears to land in Upper cards and
the usual manga fashion though we get
absolutely cucked as it goes away into a
past conversation between Mr yosikawa
and their current mentally insane lawyer
there haggaruma refuses to become a
judge because he felt like his Ambitions
in life weren't good enough as explained
that he's reminded of his memory because
Yuji for some bizarre reason confessed
to a crime he did not commit the
evidence on the retrial was about
sakona's Massacre and hegaruma knows
that Yuji wasn't the one who committed
that crime so he can't seem to
understand why Yuji would confesses
something that he didn't do because of
his confusion over this hagarumo
willingly deactivates The Executioner's
sword allowing yuji's insanely strong
uppercut like this is just pure physical
strength by the way like look how ripped
he is right now boys this punch directly
hits him in the body probably cracking a
rebel too and seated him crashing back
into the seeds before he even bothers to
get up and he hurt a guru mistakes to
Yoji that the absence of reason or
control signifies non-components he adds
that sakuna was in position of the body
and since Yoji didn't surrender control
willingly he is innocent who she doesn't
see it that way though and he still
claims responsibility for it believing
that death really only occurred because
he's too weak Yuji who's still confused
over why he deactivated his technique in
the first place asks him so getting back
up now hegaruma explains that he
remembered why he got into law in the
first place as there are still other
weak people out there who need his help
hagaruma invites Yuji to sit down after
he's gotten his clothes back on and it
creates the government's 100 points
however before he does so he asks the
young sorcerer if he's ever killed
anyone on purpose twitch Yuji somebody
responds that he has then in a quick
flash we see the moments preceding
keita's trial and how hecaroma had
brutally murdered the prosecutor and
judge thinking on this he asks Yuji if
he felt awful about it as well
so that there officially brings the
first beat down of this like amazing
of this amazing colony to an end but one
thing I do want to say is I goddamn love
pick a Roman and I really really hope
that he sticks around any story after
this point even after the culling game
like ends it would be nice to have him
as a great addition to like the Jujutsu
Tech staff honestly I think he is just
truly a good person who is blinded by
just how Society is and his insane
increase in power that he just received
from kinjaku which makes me also wonder
are all these new techniques and modern
day civilians have found themselves
worth actually just another
reincarnation and instead of a person
being reincarnated it's technically a
curse technique itself that's being
placed inside of an individual who meets
the right conditions anyways now that
the two are just chilling out hagarumo
tells us cocaine to add a new rule to
the culling game that allows players to
transfer points between one another as
usually anxiously Waits cocaine relays
the message to the game master but just
moments later he breathes the sigh of
relief as the rule is allowed and
hagaruma transfers one of his points to
to Yuji so that neither of them will be
affected by curse technique removal for
at least 19 days abruptly getting up now
and leaving her groomer says goodbye but
Yuji who's just like your weight up dude
asks him what he's going to do now he
explains to him that he wants to use
hegaruma's strength to help them in the
culling game but the lawyer explains
that he killed a few people before
coming to Tokyo due to how he feels
about this now he wants to take
responsibility and plan to turn himself
in once the barriers reopen but until
that time happens he's going to ponder
his best course of action and doesn't
feel comfortable staying around Yuji
because it just makes him hate himself
even more sadly hecarima leaves the
theater leaving our boy alone to lament
of this situation despite accomplishing
his goal now we move on to the next
round of heat boys seeking massive
Battle of this dopas Arc here I don't
know if you've seen like gigay's recent
posted with Hana and him honoring
Takashi sensei's ethereal level of
writing but dude said he hoped he could
warm the pages to a similar degree to
Takashi since his writing and years to
come I don't like actually believe how
humble this goat is I he doesn't realize
he's already sitting his pages on
freaking fire and has definitely become
one of the hottest dudes on the Block
where they're constantly releasing manga
each week especially in the western side
of the world meanwhile and over the
other side of the Tokyo Colony regica
means mikami as he says he can already
tell that the young man is strong just
based on a shikigami unbeknownst to Remy
Reggie was actually just using her to
lure in potential allies and now seeing
migami here he asks him to join their
group then asks what he knows about the
culling game well that means any Master
thumb making me reveals that it is a
ritual for bringing Japanese people to
the other side so that they're no longer
considered human hearing this
explanation Richie cracks up and asks
smigami if he knows kinjaku surprising
the younger sorcerer as he had figured
he'd run into a person with a connection
to kinshaku sooner or later which he
explains that the ritual explanation is
probably just the cover for kingjaku's
real plan and hold I don't want to spoil
anything I want to like catch up and
probably reveal like the true play
myself because Reggie may look like a
silly mofo but this dude is a genius for
stating this cheeky foreshadowing right
here continuing with his big brain
explanation assuming that 1 000 players
were equally divided among 10 colonies
Reggie suggests that each colony of 800
players is top heavy in regard to the
player's skill level players like
hashimo and hegaruma are much stronger
than most of the other combatants and
between the two of them they have
already eliminated roughly 60 players
within just the first 12 days which
makes sense to Mega me as like the Tokyo
calling number one has been extremely
quiet ever since he entered he asks
Reggie if all these strong have already
waited out all of the Wake this early on
in the game and if the game has reached
a deadlock due to those circumstances
Reggie confirms this then goes on to
explain that the transferral process
isn't just a way to spread out players
but actually a way to stimulate a second
Awakening of new modern day peoples
curse techniques some of the weaker
people even die during their transfer
process but this doesn't benefit the
ritual in the same way that a drawn out
merely would Reggie dropped a freaking
bomb saying that kinjaku is currently
overseas in China meeting with the
government officials there so like was
that Beijing I don't know what Mr G and
his boys are doing over there but
anyways he explains that he's pretty
certain that kinjaka will drop his own
metaphorical bomb on all of the players
once Only The Strongest Ones remain at
that point Reggie believes the Cullen
game will have served its purpose so for
now he's just focused on Gathering
strong allies and storing points mikimi
asks how Remy fits into his plan because
he's obviously a weakling with no value
to which Reggie clarifies that Remy is
useful for learning people as they tend
to drop their guard around a woman
making me asks Richie at the total
points of everyone in the group adds up
to 100 to which really confirms that
they have over a hundred points in total
having me confirmed on his suspicions
making me reveals that a new rule will
soon be added that allows players to
give points to each other he demands
that Reggie and all of his allies hand
over their points to him and only then
will he consider joining them
immediately Reggie is like oh oh well I
guess this tour has broken down causing
a random fodder player to shoot out
behind me me and try to attack him with
a set of claw hands so obviously this
dude is another of the the guys I like
to call it body modification curse users
with Yuji we had the cap dude and of
course the rocket here girl now we've
got claw man right here Mega me manages
to slip into the Stone's Shadow then
there's this Divine dog attacks Reggie
he reappears from below the fodder claw
man picking him up and simply throwing
his ass off the side of the building
it's per usual though nikami always
double Taps his opponents and commands
in a way to dive from him shockingly
player and slamming him into the ground
below probably murking him back in the
building two kitchen knives are suddenly
shoved into the Divine dog's mouth
incapacitating the shikagami as Mega me
turns back Reggie says that he knows
what he's up to and wants his adversary
he'll die if he doesn't fight for real
on cue a random eye suddenly appears
over the side of the building next to
Mega me and abruptly detonates causing
an explosion which almost takes out even
Reggie above them we find a player named
iori hazanoki one of Reggie's allies and
another of those body modification users
the Now 1 sorcerer begins breaking off
some more of his teeth while asking if
the target is dead however nigami is
saying quickly darting out of the smoke
and immediately avoiding a follow-up
attack sent by Remy he manages to grab
your hair and slams her onto the ground
aggressively he asks her if she's
heading north but before she can answer
hazanoki jumps down from the floor above
and tosses his teeth at Mega me at the
same time Reggie also sends through a
few receipts that transform into gas and
splash all over Mega me soaking hum then
in some crazy ass combination with the
gasoline hazanoki detonates his teeth
resulting in a massive blast that erupts
through the top of the building
seemingly taking out both Remy and mega
me exit in a room Reggie asks if they're
finished but hazanoki says he saw migami
duck into another room to avoid taking
damage inside of that said room nigami
moves a door that he used to protect
himself in Remy and asks her if she
understands now as the explosions could
have easily killed her as well proving
that she's completely and utterly
disposable making me tries to leave her
behind but Remy attempts to stab him
again with her hair then ends certainly
switching up she desperately begs Mega
me to say that he likes her and then you
will protect her disgusted making me
realizes that Remy is the type of trash
who only cares about words rather than
someone's actions chizuru so like
remember that random dude Mega me
disposal of right at the style of the
scuffle well it turns out he didn't
actually die and stupidly the man
decides to reach when they battle he
compliments Mega me for getting the
better of him before but notes that this
student must be in rough shape now he
mentions it was a pain scale in the
building and hearing this Mega me is
like yo what what are you dumb dude why
didn't you take the stairs suddenly both
of their code games appear and announce
that a new rule has been added to the
culling game so this is obviously the
point in the arc that Yuji and
higgeruma's battle ends with them
finally adding that new role surprise
and reinvigorated making me Smiles
instantly he restarts the fight kicking
he fought a full back and summoning his
prolific Max elephant which materializes
inside the building completely
destroying the upper floors as it comes
thundering down sticking with lightning
itself nigami then uses no way to catch
himself allowing him to mount chizuru in
mid-air after getting on top and still
falling making me slashes his face over
and over with the health of a sword
before jumping off and kicking him into
the ground below having crashed heavily
into the ground Chooser who curses
Megami yet before he can even get up
Mickey who ain't no damn Yuji simply
slashes his face open with his sword and
eliminates him for a moment make me
questions what he's doing because I need
more points in the future but quickly
refocuses by reminding himself that
sakumi won't have to participate in the
Kelly now Esco game rewards him with
five points migumi reaffirms to himself
that he just needs to deal with the
difficulties as they come descending
down to ground level with their
opponences Reggie has left surprise and
even embarrassed by chizuru's lack of
skill back with our boy he notices that
he's still at number two to one and is
now feeling the effects of the first
explosion thinking on what to do for a
moment he deduces that he can't Flay or
use his domain expansion because the
environment still isn't compatible with
his technique before he can think up of
anything to do hasn't Nokia abruptly
spits out another one of his bomb teeth
but completely and utterly out of
nowhere someone literally no one saw
coming showed up and took the blast face
first like an actual champion to protect
him as all of them stand there utterly
confused the newcomer named for Mexico
tacaba who was the failing comedian that
I introduced right at the end of the
previous Jiu Jitsu Kaizen video or it
might even mean the one before that one
now well hey and one of them like
Superhero level voices states that
two-on-one fights are unfair and calls
Richie and his minion complete cowards
he adds that their attacks have done
zero damage however it's shown that the
attack completely busted open his face
and hid making it clear that it was in
fact heard confusing Mega me looking at
Mega me takaba decides to help him
because their 35 year old can tell
whether someone is good or bad just by
their face yet after looking at him
again he realizes that Mega me actually
has a bad face but writes it off is all
revisionist which is just obviously
wrong I mean to say relative making is
just left stunned with this new person
but regardless of his personality this
random man just saved him so the
Jiu-Jitsu High student is willing to
trust him for now Regine hazanoki don't
even recognize takaba they try asking
what time period is from to cover though
who isn't even listening to them
explains that his costume is based on a
funny superhero causing his intimidation
factor to suddenly flare up while
preparing to tell another absolutely
terrible joke the enemy Duo prepare for
an attack but to cover darts into a JoJo
whisk pose and tells a joke they could
say did silent reaction to Harbor
screams that damn it's a tough crowd but
continues to Hype himself up nonetheless
even though his opponents are stiff
takaba will continue to do what he does
best because he's an Entertainer of the
highest degree he screams flying forward
and delivering an insane double-footed
flying dropkick that connects with
hazanoki's face sending him crashing
into a nearby building sent in there
Reggie notes the shift into Carver's
output of curse energy and quickly
realizes that the failing comedian is
actually super strong tacaba stunting on
all of them does a handstand while
explaining that he's an old-school
performer who's pro-violence who's in
the king Fusion to his Advantage making
me tries to launch a surprise attack on
Reggie from his own shadow but his foe
manages to jump away from the ground in
time to avoid it now back with his new
teammate migami tries to explain to him
has a no he's exploding body part but
only ends up getting annoyed telling
takaba to stop getting so close to his
face bringing out cocaine they use him
to confirm that hegaruma was indeed the
one who added a new role he's surprised
and is sure to see that Yuji had
completed their mission because of this
he states that he's done with his colony
and tells Reggie he'll let him go if he
backs off Richie just straight up
annoyed now refuses because he needs to
make up for his teammates lost points
over in their absolutely ruined building
hazunuku recovers from the Dropkick that
he just suffered and calls out to zakaba
the comedian though still just
absolutely ignores him and instead
introduces himself properly to Mega me
since tacaba is most likely going to end
up killing the bomb guy making me
requests that he take hazanoki's point
if possible to which he accepts on the
condition that he continues to entertain
as first and foremost he is a performer
satisfied takaba begins sparking almost
exposing himself to the young man while
hazanoki in return sends an explosive
eye directs the atom not phase to cover
simply knocks it away with a random
paper fan he manages to close the
distance on his opponent sliding in
behind him and utterly destroying his
rectum with pervy sages Infamous 1 000
years of pain seen in his enemy into a
severe belt of pain enraged and getting
utterly photorized as the Noki swings at
him but takaba immediately follows up
with a powerful kick to his dorm that
sends his opponent through another
building standing there Mega measly
flabbergasted with takaba's show of
strength and expresses that he's glad he
isn't his enemy twister Kaba tells him
to stay alive while he goes off and
pounds his opponents some more over with
Reggie he stands there thinking that
zakaba is toast either way because
hezonoki will go all out after being
mocked so much with his objective
complete Megami tells his adversary to
worry about himself so that he can fight
him for real instantly he summons his
max elephant leaving Reggie blown away
that Mega me has such a large shikagami
in his Arsenal Max elephant attempts to
spray regime with a torrent of water but
he somehow manages to dive away from the
burst attempting to take him by surprise
he can be leaps from the building above
but Richie notices in time and throws a
receipt which transforms into a net and
a snares the recently created rabbits
Mega me himself though narrowly a
voicing it and jumps onto a chain-linked
fence to break his fall as Mega me jumps
back into the road rigid activates his
innate curse technique contractual
Recreation and transforms several
receipts into kitchen knives though Sim
knives fly forward towards mikami as
projectiles but he's able to deflict
them with a blade of his own some
rabbits are pierced by these knives
allowing rigidism eyes that unlike the
other shikigami they can reappear
regardless of how many are destroyed
which he figures that Mega me has likely
figured out how his curse technique
Works due to this he uses a receipt to
recreate the contract and endows himself
with a relaxing two night stay at a
five-star Japanese Inn in contrast Mega
me gets worn down from the constant
fighting on top of having you seem
lowering his overall capacity bridges
surmises that Miami can't reconjour his
shikigami after they're injured and
without the flexibility the Divine dog
provides him he's Limited in his options
the old school ads that both of them
lack big finishing moves and will need
to pick away at each other over time to
achieve Victory torch migami is like
yeah bro in that case I'm absolutely
so I'm a run for now out of
nowhere no waiting swoops down gravy
Mega me however Reggie quickly summons
the trash taste boys drones equipped
with the lost luggage cameras to follow
his opponents through the sky while he
watches on a phone then summoning your
moped Reggie begins to pursue his
adversary through the streets and tracks
migami's position to a gymnasium Reggie
questions whether he really tried
escaping or if he's in fact trying to
lure the fight inside of the gym Mickey
is glad to see that the area is spacious
looking up though he suddenly sees
Ridgid appear on the balcony who asks
what his opponents is plotting making me
replies that big Reggie is likely
planning something as well and the
letter claims that it's hard to tell
because Sorcerers are nothing but con
artists which is completely utterly true
and I love the whole idea of Reggie's
thoughts on Sorcerers here it's all
about like conning your enemy into
believing you've played your final move
but actually you've just laid a trap and
con him into a false sense of security
anyways with the main part of this
absolutely insane battle begin suddenly
two trucks appear out of nowhere and
come crashing through the walls of the
building acting quickly making me is
just able to slip under the vehicles yet
as he watches them crash into the other
wall two potted plants are recreated
above Mega me they're dropped down onto
his head cracking his skull open Richie
follows up by repeatedly slicing
megamy's back and left arm with a small
knife Megami tries to retreat but gets
distracted by the unorthodox projectile
Richie had just created he's taken off
guard when they silly old carrot begins
to break apart and reveals a hidden
kitchen knife inside shooting forth the
Knight stabs directly into migami's
elbow while Richie then follows up with
a brutal front kick to his face having
been knocked down negamy slides across
the gym floor thoroughly overpowered
it's explained that other things Reggie
recreates behave like shikigami
obviously knives and other things like
that can't normally fly through the air
but Reggie is able to get them to do so
with a single command big freaking Mega
me though a man made of a much darker
material response by stating that
barrier techniques are difficult for him
and he's simply unable to make an
artificial environment over a real one
however Megami doesn't need to
physically create a barrier no instead
he can use the entire gymnasium as a
perfect space for his domain as planned
Mega me casts has got a damn domain
expansion the insane kamira Shadow
Garden and forcibly encloses the barrier
around the gym to trap Reggie inside
ceiling has faked Richie who really
doesn't think migami was a sorcerer
capable of using domain expansion as
utterly taken by surprise immediately
though he activates his special
anti-domain technique called Hollow
wicker basket which if you see my video
going over like all of the jjk barrier
types you know that this is the original
form of the current simple domain Reggie
believes he successfully protected
himself from the domain until four toads
appear from the liquid below his feet
and wrap up both his legs with their
tongues confused which he doesn't
understand how he's been hit after using
Hollow wicker basket and to explain that
technically Reggie's technique does
nullify this seed guaranteed hit from a
domain but because megami's domain isn't
complete and doesn't actually have a
can't miss attack it only serves as an
extension to his cursed energy and 10
Shadows technique that soul and
Perfection has taken Richie off guard
and making me notices his expression
change before Reggie can finish berating
Mega me for getting cocky he's ambushed
by two Shadow clones Reggie is unable to
avoid the barrage of hairs due to the
Toad's tongues preventing his movements
after getting pummeled over and over
would you post back to the ground and
summons combat knives to sever the
Toad's tongues free to move again he
summons a machete and prepares the
counter attack however nigami's clone
prevents Reggie from gaining any
momentum by coming up from below to
graber's League then the Clone throws
Reggie towards mikimi's main body who's
also armed with his sword and already
bringing it down on Reggie somehow
though Reggie is able to block this
attack like his reflexes are literally
insane here but now the only reverse
cards been played by our boy and it's a
three-on-one with the other Shadow clone
appearing and elbowing him directly in
the dome heavily damaged now Richie Just
narrowly defends a slash from Mega me
and commends the Sorcerer for his
increased function of the curse
technique considering it worse than a
lethal domain Reggie is aware that if
migami uses Max elephant and showers him
with water he'll lose this fight
refusing to allow that to happen he
activates his coustic neck and releases
a multitude of receipts into the ear
above his head mikumi tries to destroy
the receipts using no way but it's just
not quick enough to stop ridge's
contractual Recreation from active
invading three cars are suddenly
generated from the receipts was dropped
straight into the shadowy floor which he
understands that the entire domain is
migami Shadow but noticed that Megami
has only kept one curse tool onto the
length of this entire fight he theorizes
that this is because Mega me has to be
the weight of anything kept within his
shadow and now Reggie is using the cast
to turn the domain's conditions back on
mikami heavy mean forced to the ground
under the immense weight Richard
believes mikami might be able to summon
shikigami still so he keeps his guard up
and plans to keep on piling weight until
his opponent is completely crushed Mega
me though like we all learned this
throughout the first battle against that
silly old cursed womb he literally is
insane and the dude does not care about
life anymore to the point that he tells
Reggie he's forgotten something
important he reminds him that an
incomplete domain is still a domain and
there is Shadow All Around both of them
migami who doesn't care certainly
conscious Max elephant from these
Shadows above Richie causing the massive
shikigami to drop down directly on top
of him having turned their fire into a
10 weightlifting competition making me
remains confident as he asks Richie
which of the two of them will be crushed
first let's explain that the average
human being can withstand about five to
six units of G-Force before losing
Consciousness making me weigh 60
kilograms and is currently carrying 2.4
tons of weight which equates to 40 units
of G-Force a fully matured elephant
weighs three to six tons and megami's
domain increases the Precision of his
curse technique replicating Max
elephant's weight realistically with an
intense weight falling atop him Reggie
fractures his right fibula and heel bone
due to the pressure alone hitting lament
over not saving the trucks he used
earlier for more weight at this moment
he's been soaked with water by Max
elephant but there are still receipts he
can release including the special Ace
that he has up a sleeve Reggie wonders
if he can enter the shadow below him to
release his Ace and finish off Megami he
dismisses this idea though because
anything caught in the shadow after it's
dispelled might be unable to escape
furthermore he's unsure of what it's
actually like inside of this sticky
shadow every substance he decides this
option is too risky and tries to
withstand the elephant's weight while
releasing his Ace attack regi attempts
to hold up the elephant with one arm
while taking out another receipt but
before he can fully activate his
contractual Recreation Reggie succumbs
to Max elephant's immense weight and
falls into the shadow below him without
any buoyancy or resistance inside of the
Shadow Reggie Falls and begins to lose
Consciousness due to the lack of oxygen
laying there above his likely defeated
opponent making me wait until he's sure
that Reggie is dead before dispelling
the domain and emptying his shadow
suddenly and coming back like a damn
King riding one of his cars would he
flies back exploding through to the
surface rescue from certain demise now
he can means making me strength and
emits he's a strong sorcerer before
immediately stating that he's even
stronger though he activates another
contractual Recreation and summons a
swore two-story freaking wooden house
that weighs at least 30 tons to crush
mikami in the next second Megami makes
an extremely drastic move despite using
his Ace Richie somehow abruptly finds
himself underwater again and being
strangled from behind as explained now
Megami is using his extreme weight to
drown Richie but because of just the
immense Force that's being placed on him
he has to deactivate the curse technique
and then register the weight of the
objects before he does actually end up
dying himself coming to Regis able to
swim back to the surface and realizes
that he's inside of a pool on the
basement level of the gymnasium making
me fled back into his shadow and entered
the domain making it so that the house
broke the floor and forced Reggie into
the pool below it's unclear how Mickey
me was able to move despite the immense
weight but Ricky theorizes that he did
so by ejecting himself from the shadow
kind of like a seesaw making me strolls
up on his opponent and tells Reggie his
receipts are too weak to use now
normally splashing their seats with
water isn't enough to make the print
fade so that alone isn't enough to stop
Reggie from reducing things however so
can the receipts prevents Reggie from
fulfilling the condition that requires
burning of the receipts which G also
notes that making me can't summon
shikigami anymore to watch the sorcerer
agrees stating that from now on this is
a straight up physical fight to the
death Reggie though doesn't actually
believe this he expects Megami to summon
a sugigami and plans on countering
Megami as soon as he lets up dartinan
Reggie's initial base attack gets palmed
off but as he planned he uses that
momentum to sing meghami's sword arm
bouncing back having no defense left
Reggie looks loose with a multitude of
kicks smashing the young sorcerer over
and over again making me admits that
Reggie is a tough opponent made evident
visibility to withstand Max elephant
he's also a talented martial artist with
some really dope ass techniques but he
just isn't fast enough just before
Reggie is able to land a direct hit on
Megami a portion of the far left side of
Reggie's face his ear and much of his
left shoulder are completely sheared off
by someone he thought that he dealt with
already having suffered a lethal blow at
blinding speed Richie looks back to see
no one other than the Divine dog
totality which is just pissed atom while
the dog even has two scars in its nose
from the knives it's explained that Mega
me was waiting until Reggie had
completely dismissed the dog and hearing
this would you repeat that a sorcer is
indeed nothing but a con artist as he
collapses to the ground and a pull of
his own blood Reggie lays bleeding out
on the ground looking up at Mega me and
realizes that the domain and the Paul
concealed that Mega me could still
strike with his Divine dog Mega me
didn't flee into the gym using no way
instead hit Lord of Reggie inside
standing above him make me inquires as
to what ridge's relationship to master
tinken is it's shown that there really
isn't much of a relationship he only
knows him as the hermit who is Immortal
and isn't surprised to find out he's
still alive at this time defeated with
dignity Reggie tells his cocaine to
transfer all 41 of his points to Mega me
with your boy is a little annoyed about
but Reggie tells him to just consider it
a good deed before death he ads that
he's just a spectator and isn't close to
kingjaku at all well this final word
said Richie tells his executioner to let
fate toy with him before he also dies
like a fool moments later mikimi
received five points for the death of
Reggie Starr damn is actually such a
firefight like I love how much
foreshadowing for future events are
people throughout the story here like is
that how Megami is going to end up dying
having zacona who is fate in this
context I guess toy with him before he
kills him like a fool and again those
who are like past chapter 200 now also
know big Richie was correct when it came
to this just being the beginning of
something even larger back to the fight
over the other side of the city a
massive explosion a set off on the roof
of a building hazanoki who's still
fighting with takaba wonders if he's
finally had his Target yet the comedian
appears right beside him and comically
encourages him to stay focused because
his opponent is a tough one continuously
irritated by takaba's Antics hazanuki
tries to punch him only for his first to
slide off this new dude's weird Saucy
coating hazanuki is just really
frustrated by this fight as he doesn't
understand why to cover won't take any
damage regardless of how many times he
gets bombed kogane interrupts the battle
for a moment to inform them both that
Reggie has been eliminated surprise
hazanoki decides to walk away from the
fight entirely initially Takara is fine
with us telling his opponent to bathe
and brush his teeth once he gets home
but after thinking for a moment and
sticking with the original plan takaba
starts to piss the hazanoki for his
point only to be repeatedly denied as it
skips away from them it's explained that
big fumuhiko's curse technique is called
comedian it's actually like too broken
of a technique so broken in fact that it
has the possibility to even rival that
of gojos by anything that takaba thinks
is kind of funny or is funny in general
becomes reality itself for him but
unfortunately you know takaba is a
little bit mentally lacking and is
completely unaware of how this even
works elsewhere she's distressed because
she's always been told throughout her
life that men are supposed to be wolves
who would tear up but they've always
come to take care of her which is what
do you mean by getting torn out her pin
and New Zealand made some crazy slang
anyways she doesn't know how to go on
and still thinks that wolves will
continue to help her until she's
cornered by a deadly Hound which turns
out to be migami's divine dog before
mikami can make good honest threats to
kumi's voice randomly appears and tells
her brother to stop before he kills
someone in Cold Blood causing his Divine
dog to disappear and Remy surprised that
she's being lit go annoyed and just
completely exhausted now making me tell
the sister to just shut up before he
collapses to the ground unconscious just
as happens though like literally
something I didn't even think like
happened throughout this Arc happens no
one other than the angel herself
hanakurasu descends upon his body
so that officially brings us to the very
end of what is Tokyo Colony number one
from Jiu Jitsu Kaizen obviously this Arc
here is absolutely insane but then again
half the arc is literally just either
meeting new people or just having like
the explanations of their techniques
explained to us before they end up
either leaving or end up dying so I hope
they you know like end up playing some
kind of role later in the story we know
now like for a fact that ridge's role or
like the stuff that Reggie kind of said
ends up playing a role later in the
story so it's good to know that not
everything from his character was like
absolutely useless and that's kind of
why if you notice I put out a video like
a week ago going over how I thought
Reggie and his fight against Mega me was
the most underrated fight from
throughout the Cullen game and Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen just merely for the fact that
when it first came out everyone thought
it was out of trash and they didn't
enjoy it and they hated the the action
in comparison to what was going on
beforehand but now you can see that the
action that actually went down here and
the stuff between Mega me and Reggie is
an extremely important factor to what is
going currently on in this story to what
is going on currently in this story
obviously if you have enjoyed this Arc
here the next Arc is the Sendai Colony
number no number one on there one
because there isn't two of them there's
only one seemed by colony and then after
that we have the Tokyo calling in number
two with our boy freaking Hikari going
up against Hajime kashimo who was the
other character tased way back in like
the preparation Arc I'm pretty sure so a
while ago now but you've got those
videos to look forward to up in the
future along with a bunch of other
chainsaw man videos and all of that but
anyway if you guys are new around here I
want to watch more stuff just like this
then make sure you hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as it really helps out with
pushing my content to a bunch of new
amazing people anyway enough of that for
now it's been a professional degenerate
diavolo and I'll see you all enable bye